jessas hallo ihr lieben wir sind in
griechenland in santorini wir machen den
kraft und seinen jahresurlaub und wir
haben gedacht wir müssen für euch ein
video drehen ich bin schon richtig
eingefleischte griechen hier
ich habe mir hier dieses kleid heute aus
einer boutique gekauft und jetzt mache
ich mir voll dabei und habe mir gedacht
ich nehme euch da jetzt mal mit also wir
machen ja hier für sieben tage urlaub
wir zeigen euch gleich auch bis draußen
aussieht traumhaft also istanbul rechten
ort den können wir euch total empfehlen
zum entspannen zum runterkommen die
sonne tanken und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal frappe das ist so ein
bisschen das ist das nationalgetränk der
griechen glaube ich habe nicht so ein
bisschen auch gewundert ich habe ja den
balkon a coffee gemacht und eigentlich
war ich mir zuerst es da und monaco
wurde glaube ich von bts glaube ich in
meiner von bts hat das mal getrennt
gesammelt
ja ich also ich habe es total gerne in
den punkten dran gewöhnen so ich habe
jetzt hier
nescafé tatsächlich das ist so typisch
griechisch nescafé um zucker dass ich
jetzt hier eine schüssel und eigentlich
leute gibts dafür aus ein extrafach tmx
sei das sind diese diese
milchaufschäumer diese per hand gehen
das habe ich aber nicht ich wollte extra
in der stadt und habe fragen die man
eingibt ziemlich haben man nicht mit
gewisse kaltes wasser dazu auch im
unterschied zum balkon an kaffee da
hatte ich ja heißes drin ein bisschen
ich würde mal schätzen hoch drei
esslöffel ich schreibe euch alles sommer
ganz genau in die infobox
was ich hier genau getan ab ungefähr und
es muss der film gut leiden schneebesen
machen und das wird das glaube ich so
ein bisschen dauern
ja da sagt man damit können wir auch den
kuchen backen werde und zwar den porto
portugal olympic demir werde ich liegen
griechischen einigen kuchen backen das
seht ihr dann aber in meiner instructors
director und jetzt wird laut wird ruhig
volkswagen ruft diese über das paket
[Musik]
rund 6000 jahre später fertig ist muss
so fest sein guckt und jetzt gebe ich
das eben zwei gläser schon gleichmäßig
verteilt zu haben sein
denn heute morgen noch auswärts bestellt
ist besser als der allgäuer kopf ich sag
euch auch nachher warum so und jetzt
kommen da ganz ganz traditionell
eiswürfel rein und das ganze mit kaltem
wasser aufgegossen jetzt im vergleich
der dallgower coffee da war ja erst mal
80 prozent milch und oben nur dieser
schaum und irgendwie ja weil er nicht so
geil aber diesen frappe finde ich
hingegen richtig richtig gut und da kann
man auch selbst bestimmen wie viel
zucker man möchte auch wenn man bestellt
hier fragen die mir möchten sie viel zu
kw nicht mit milch oder ohne ist ohne
richtig coolen
[Musik]
und so ist der jetzt eigentlich schon
fertig aber man hat die option noch
milch mit dazu zudem habe ich doch jetzt
wirklich milch fans oder ok wir nehmen
jetzt auch ein schuss milch mit rein und
nicht wie gesagt okay jetzt mega 4 1
kaum sondern eigentlich echt nur um show
und dann kann man was noch richtig schön
kalt genießen
doch dann kommt die wildschweine und
fertig war das sieht so gut aus
perfekt für den sommer leute über sollen
jetzt kommt die chance die shops immer
die konstanz
[Musik]
und wir lassen euch noch ganz viele
liebe urlaubsgrüße da wir hatten die
sieben tage einfach so nötig ich habe
mit hamza auch schon drüber gesprochen
wir haben in den letzten zwölf monaten
einfach so viel gas gegeben sind so
gewachsen
das freut mich extrem aber andererseits
das ist das was man eigentlich auf
youtube und auf instagram lich sieht wir
haben so ein druck auf unseren schultern
weil wir haben in der letzten zeit 20
mitarbeiter zusätzlich eingestellt die
wollen am ende des monats alle im
kühlschrank füllen da haben sie eine
gewisse verantwortung wir haben gedacht
okay jetzt einmal kurz die reißleine
ziehen kurz abschalten für sieben tage
und wenn wir zurückkommen dann werden
neue projekte angegangen mit wieder
ordentlich gas gegeben und deshalb haben
wir natürlich geht und auch videos gilt
regelmäßig genau neue tolle rezepte für
euch und wir brauchten das jetzt einfach
und daher euch doch einen wunderschönen
tag eine wunderschöne zeit im sonnigen
deutschland und bis sonntag dann kommt
nämlich mein neues video online
bis bald teure kettchen
[Musik]
das war